being victimized by a circumstance in
your life literally means that that
event that circumstance that person that
condition is actually causing you to
feel emotionally and think in terms of
memories equal to that circumstance and
that circumstances actually changes your
state of being so you're thinking the
same way and you're feeling the same way
in response to the environment is the
same we can guarantee that your life is
going to stay the same because you're
the same yes that person why are you
unhappy why are you frustrated why are
you sad they'll say that this condition
this this person is actually making me
feel and think this way well anything
that makes us feel and think a certain
way that we don't think we have any
control over for the most part we're
victims so we're as a species become
victimized by the conditions in our life
and it's the environment then that is
controlling the way we feel in the way
we think so the idea is if you can
change the way you think and change the
way you feel could you begin to produce
outcomes or effects in your life that
cause you to believe that you're the
creator of your life instead of the
victim of your life if you keep thinking
the same thoughts if you keep making the
same choices you keep doing the same
things you keep creating the same
experiences you keep feeling the same
emotions I don't know let's be
conservative you do that for 10 years
you would have to agree with me then
that it would become more automatic if
you become more unconscious your
personality creates your personal
reality that's it that is it and your
personality is made of how you think how
you act and how you feel so keep
thinking the same way keep acting the
same way keep feeling the same way your
personality is the same and your
personal reality will be the same as
well so if you wanted to change your
life if you wanted to change your
personal reality you would have to
change your personality and then you'd
have to start thinking about what you've
been thinking about and decide if you
really want to believe that any longer
and when does the story end it's that
moment that you become so conscious of
that thought you're so tired of it
you're so aware of it that you wouldn't
never let it slip by your awareness ever
again so I think there's two times the
door to the subconscious mind opens up
when we wake up in the morning and we go
to bed at night and it's simple brain
chemistry and simple physiology we have
a circadian rhythm as soon as there's
light our body has been pretty much
programmed that we begin to release
serotonin different chemicals that kind
of wake us up so our brain waves go from
Delta to Theta to Alpha to Beta and we
kind of slide up this way and then
you're back to conscious awareness local
in space and time when you go to bed at
night you go from beta to Alpha to Theta
to Delta and you slide down now if
you're stressed you can't stop thinking
you stay in beta you're thinking
actually is arousing the body because
you're thinking about your problems you
can't slide down those two points in the
day when we wake up in the morning go to
bed at night when we're and when alpha
or our analytical facilities are
suppressed we're in Theta we're in a
hypnotic State and the door between the
conscious mind and the subconscious mind
is wide open what separates the
conscious mind from the subconscious
mind is the analytical mind so you
suppress analytical facilities you can
program anybody to do anything most
people try to create a new personal
reality as the same personality and it
doesn't work we literally have to become
someone else in other words thoughts are
the language of the brain and feelings
are the language of the body and how you
think and how you feel creates a state
of being so most people have experiences
in their life that brand them
emotionally they feel fear they feel
anger they feel bitterness they feel
frustration they feel insecurity and
those emotions then become part of their
identity so once they think certain
thoughts that turn on certain circuits
in their brain that are equal to their
insecurity and then they feel insecure
the moment they feel insecure they think
more insecure thoughts which makes more
chemicals for them to feel insecure and
the repetition of that cycle over time
conditions the body to subconsciously
become the mind of insecurity so then
the person says I am insecure and
whenever you say I am anything you're
commanding your mind and body towards a
destiny also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I've designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there if
your brain is a record of the past and
you are living by the same emotions that
have defined you for the last 10 years
and you keep thinking the same thoughts
that make the same chemicals and those
same chemicals Drive the same thoughts
then your body
as the uncle conscious mind does not
know the difference between an actual
experience in your life that creates an
emotion and an emotion that you're
creating by thought alone and so your
body is believing it's in the same past
experience 24 hours a day seven days a
week 365 days a year and your body is
programmed into the past and you can
create a new future holding on to the
emotions of the past nobody changes
until they change their energy when you
change your energy you change your life
it's the way it is when you stop using
your enemy to reaffirm your addiction to
hatred when you stop using your best
friend to reaffirm your addiction to
suffering when you stop using your
Facebook to reaffirm your addiction to
insecurity you stop that whole process
and you start going Inward and you're no
longer relying on those outer things
that create those emotions and you start
creating those inner emotional states
you start changing your energy now
whatever is no longer a vibrational
match between you and that past present
reality is going to fall away right
they're just going to spiral out you're
no longer putting your attention on them
in other words the stronger the emotion
you feel with some problem in your life
the more you give it your attention
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy you're giving your
power away your life force lower the
volumes of that emotion you take your
attention off that person you're calling
energy back to you yeah and you're
building your own electromagnetic field
we've seen the evidence of that many
events because when people start
overcoming themselves the first day not
always but the energy of the room will
drop why because they're drawing from
the field to build their own field now
when they build their own field the next
day and the fields start interfering
with the people next to them whoop the
energy in the room just keeps going up
so now there's no longer a vibrational
match between you and your co-worker or
be prepared because that old known thing
is going to fall away because you're no
longer emotionally and energetically
connected to it so then when will you
get in that state it's not a time to try
to put it back together because at the
same time these things are unraveling
and they're moving towards chaos and
chaos is just unpredictable order right
it's novelty the newness of an
experience that you can't predict is
chaos if you apply the formula and all
Potentials in the quantum field exist as
electromagnetic potentials they are
possibilities when they begin to
synchronize coherently your brain and
heart you got a strong Wi-Fi signal
because now you're putting out a very
laser coherent signal right when there's
a synchronization between your energy
and that potential that exists in the
future but it really exists in the
present moment because that's where they
exist in the quantum now you start to
see synchronicities in your life and
those are breadcrumbs from the field
like keep going keep going you're on to
something yeah we have to get into the
operating system we have to get into
those programs and begin to reprogram
that and there's a way to do that
because the whole purpose of meditation
is to get beyond the analytical mind and
what separates the conscious mind from
the subconscious mind is the analytical
mind then the only way you're going to
know how to do that or do that is to
learn how to regulate your brain waves
and begin to slow them down so as you
begin to slow down your brain waves you
get beyond your analytical mind and
you're entering that operating system
where all those programs exist and 95
percent of Who We Are by the time and
we're 35 years old the set of memorized
behaviors unconscious emotional
reactions unconscious beliefs
perceptions hardwired attitudes that
function automatically like a computer
program that means that 95 of the time
people are unconscious how they're being
and so becoming conscious of that
overcoming even if you just say every
day I'm going to overcome my fear every
day I'm gonna overcome my depression
every day I'm going to feel better than
yesterday that act of doing that that
you're informing the system you're
putting new information into your body
that's causing your body maybe slowly
every day to begin to change and of
course some days are easier than others
but we naturally know what to do when
we're challenged to that measure the
greatest relationship that you could
ever have is with yourself taking time
to be in the presence of yourself and
ask yourself important questions like
are you happy who am I and instead of
getting up and getting on your cell
phone and getting distracted sit with
your triple filtered water or a glass of
wine or whatever you're into the
question without being distracted the
contemplation process is the building
process neurologically and for me I was
I'm a guy who loves God I'm a guy who
loves the Divine I'm a guy who loves
mystery I'm the guy who just never stops
dovetailing information and that's just
me and I never really planned on doing
any of this I mean my theory is on life
is make it up as you go along and take
the value and run and what the bleep
became a sensation and all of a sudden I
went from a normal guy to being a rock
star and I was traveling around the
world and doing conferences all over the
place I reached this point where I
realized that I wasn't living the work
and that really bothered me I was
disturbed by that I was really
uncomfortable and when you get
uncomfortable and nothing's making that
discomfort go away it's time to evolve
it's time to make a different choice and
I clearly heard in my head during one
meditation stop making the same choices
and pause I didn't know what that meant
except that I knew that I was relying on
all of this external stimulation to
build an identity that I really wasn't
and then I had to show up for people and
look a certain way and act a certain way
and that wasn't me and it got disturbing
for me and I didn't make time for myself
and make time to be the example I mean
my motive is always be the example of
everything that I teach I shouldn't be
leading in my clinic if I don't live
those principles myself if I don't live
my life that way and I believe that your
personality creates your personal
reality and in order to change your
personal reality your life it means then
that on some level we have to change
because nothing changes in our life
unless we change so if people have
understand that 90 of the thoughts that
they think every day are the same
thoughts as the day before the same
thoughts always lead to the same choices
the same choices always lead to the same
behaviors the same behaviors create the
same experiences and the same
experiences produce the very same
feelings and emotions and those same
emotions influence our very same
thoughts and our biology our circuitry
our neurochemistry or hormones or gene
expression stays the same because we're
the same but the repetition of firing
and wiring the same circuits in our
brain in the same way causes us to
create a very finite set of circuitry
that becomes our identity and our
personality and nurse cells that fire
together why are together which means
you keep doing it it gets easier for
them to fire and they run more
automatically I have a couple theories
about relationships that I think are
really important and I use the same
exact principles with my life first of
all I will never work in a relationship
and I don't think anybody should work in
a relationship I think if you're working
in a relationship something is not
clicking something is not right but if
you bring your best and the person that
you're with brings their best and you
celebrate your life together then
there's constructive interference
there's growth there's energy if you're
not at your best and you show up more
than likely you're gonna pick someone or
something apart and it's better that you
remove yourself for a period of time and
get back into your heart and present
yourself at your best and so if you're
not there and you need a mirror or
reflection then it's good to ask am I
missing something am I not seeing myself
in some way and then there's a healthy
conversation when you invited but if
you're not invited to contribute your
opinion then it's better off that you
don't so people always say I want a
loving relationship but what they really
want is happiness really
I assert that if you're not in the
present moment you're running a program
and paying attention is being present
and it's a skill just like anything else
the more you practice it the better you
get at it and you know when someone's
present with you in your life because
they're paying attention to you and you
know when they're not present with you
because they're not paying attention to
you where you place your attention is
where you place your energy so if you
have all of your attention in the
present moment you're conserving a lot
of energy to create with if I'm talking
to you and you're thinking about where
you're gonna go for lunch and who you're
going to go with and how you're going to
get there and I'm talking to you you
left the present moment and your
attention went to some future and your
energy will go down and you won't be
able to comprehend what I said if you
start thinking about what you should
have said at the staff meeting three
days ago and I'm talking to you and your
mind is back in the past you're
siphoning energy out of the present
moment into the past so people are
constantly siphoning their energy into a
familiar past or a predictable future
because that's where their attention is
and the stronger the emotions that we
feel to certain problems and conditions
in our life the more we pay attention to
them so we give our power away to our X
we give our power way to that big
problem and that's Creative Energy that
we should be able to use to create a new
future you know your personality creates
your personal reality that's it and your
personality is made with how you think
how you act and how you feel so if you
keep thinking the same way you keep
acting the same way you keep feeling the
same way everything stays the same in
your life because nothing changes in
your life until you change right so
turns out if you keep thinking the same
way making the same choices doing the
same things creating the same
experiences and feeling the same
emotions or responding to your life in
the exact same way you keep doing that
your biology tends to get more rigid we
fire and wire the same service we
hardwire our brain and they it only
takes a small stimulation or small
fodder a response to someone or
something and like a sequence of
thoughts it just turns on automatically
most people number one they get up in
the morning and the first thing they do
is they think about the problems in
their life and those problems are
memories from the past so the moment
they think about the problem interesting
in the past right every one of those
problems has an emotion attached to them
so they start feeling unhappy or
unworthy or whatever and how you think
and how you feel is your state of being
so most people's entire state of beings
in the past when they start the day so
within the familiar past they're going
to live in a predictable future right so
they get up and they check their cell
phone they check their text their
WhatsApp their Facebook they post
something on Facebook they tweet they
Twitter they check the news then they go
to the bathroom get a cup of coffee take
a shower get dressed check more emails
drive to work the same way do the same
thing so for the program people actually
lost their free will to the program wow
so if you start your day and you start
your day with this simple question
what is the greatest ideal of myself
that I can be today you ask yourself
that question now listen your body's
going to go like well we got to get a
cup of coffee
and you got to go body
uh you're not the mind I'm the mind
right now you're gonna sit here I'm
gonna feed you you're gonna get your
coffee you're gonna do all those things
but right now this is my time you're
gonna obey me right so now the body's no
longer the mind you're the mind and so
when it wants to get up and you become
aware of it and we turn back to the
present moment every time you do that's
a victory and you're changing some
aspect of yourself so then
ask yourself I do this all the time
write down four thoughts that you're
going to stay conscious of the whole day
I can't it's too hard to be surprised
the moment you become conscious of what
those thoughts are how unconscious
you've been to them all day you know for
weeks on end write down what you speak
how you speak four things you want to
change how you act
[Music]
what emotions do you live by is it
possible that you're so used to living
by guilty don't even know it's guilt it
just feels like you you allow your
energy to drop become conscious of those
states of mind and body and review them
and say this is the old self then say
what thoughts do I want to fire and wire
in my brain and start firing and wiring
and start feeling it what behaviors will
I demonstrate today what choices will I
make one day one lifetime just like you
did rehearse them rehearse the whole
entire thing begin to install the
neurological Hardware on your brain and
if you keep installing it the hardware
is going to become a software program
you're going to start thinking and
acting that way and then here's the
tough part
can you teach your body emotionally
what your future is going to feel like
before it's made manifest and don't get
up until you feel that way your
personality creates your personal
reality that's it and your personality
is made up of how you think how you act
and how you feel so the present
personality who's listening to this
podcast has created the present personal
reality called the life which means that
if you want to change your life you want
to create a new person in reality you're
gonna have to change your personality
you're gonna have to change because
nothing changes in your life until you
change so what is the understanding of
change that we've spent over 10 years
studying a way to explain what change is
because if you think 60 to 70 000
thoughts or however many thoughts in one
day and 90 of those thoughts are the
same thoughts as the day before you're
in trouble because the same thoughts
will lead to the same choices the same
choices will lead to the same behaviors
the same behaviors create the same
experiences and the same experiences
produce those very same emotions and
those same emotions influence our same
thoughts and our biology our neural
circuitry our neural chemistry our
hormones or gene expression everything
stays the same because we're the same so
it has traditionally taken crisis or
trauma or loss for someone to make up
their mind to change so the moment we
decide to change okay I want to create a
new personality a new life I got to
change my personality while this concept
called metacognition we have four brain
function you know the seed of our
conscience our frontal lobe allows us to
think about what we're thinking about to
notice how we're behaving and to become
aware of how we're feeling and the
repetition of thinking acting and
feeling in the same way causes our brain
to become hardwired into very specific
neural patterns right so that firing and
wiring over time happen so automatically
that we're unconscious of our conscious
self so the moment we become conscious
of those thoughts the moment we become
aware of those behaviors the moments we
notice those feelings we're no longer
the program in fact where the
Consciousness observing the program and
that's the first step to change it's so
important for people to remember that
they're the creators of their lives
instead of the victim of their life the
victim is saying I'm feeling this way
because that person or that circumstance
or I don't have any money is causing me
to feel this way that's my relationship
with money what that really means is I'm
using my lack to reaffirm my dependency
my addiction my conditioning that's my
relationship with money is that I put my
attention on money because I don't have
it the relationship with money is of
course built on lack and so when they
don't have it they feel bad and what
they're really saying is my outer
environment my reality is actually
controlling the way I feel and the way I
think so is why are you in a good mood
today things are going good why in a bad
mood things are going bad today so this
unconscious program victimization is
saying that we're allowing our
environment to influence the way we feel
and the way we think isn't that
victimization isn't and the stronger the
emotion we have to our lack the more we
put our attention on the fact that we
don't have it right yeah so then the
person has forgotten that they're
creating reality because what they're
creating is lack and they're creating
more of it and they try harder and they
force harder so the experiment then is
let's try it another way let's create
from the field instead of from matter
relaxing the heart and energy right on
the brain we've measure this thousand
times and all of a sudden the person
moves into these beautiful elegant
brainwave states where they're super
creative right the longer you're
conscious of that energy the more you
draw that future to you
when the brain starts functioning in a
level of order or coherence more neurons
are recruited
and bigger communities and that kind of
holism that's created is so important
the other thing we realize is that when
people really heal their heart they heal
their mind like there's no I have no
doubt about that you cannot do one
without the other and when there's
enough energy in the heart and we we've
seen this we've we've got the we've got
the technology to see that when the
heart starts working when people start
doing it properly there's this low
frequency in the heart that starts to
rise it's only indigenous to the heart
because they have their attention on it
where you place your attentions where
you place your energy so they're filling
the gas tank up and when it gets to a
certain point here comes the
parasympathetic nervous system saying
get out of the stress response get
relaxed then all of a sudden you think
that would be over
but it's not then the parasympathetic
nervous system drops down and the
sympatheter nervous system comes up and
when the sympathetic nervous comes up
now the person's relaxed and awake like
they're really relaxed in their heart
and they're really awake in their brain
that state
is so much better than being stressed
out and unconscious in a program right
so turns out
when you get to that state when the
heart starts informing the brain it
resets the Baseline
for the trauma that's stored in the
brain and the amygdala it's informing
the brain that the event is over because
the emotion that they're feeling is
dragging the body out of the past yes
right to the present when they feel the
glory that really rich feeling where
it's like oh my God this is something I
haven't felt since I was nine years old
or six years old and it's this familiar
feeling their heart the words many
people use blows wide open
when they look back at their past their
trauma
the loss the Betrayal the abuse sexually
physically emotionally
so many times the person doesn't want to
change one thing what is that because it
brought them to this moment and now the
moment is okay and all of that's okay
because I'm okay and they look back at
their betrayers and their abusers and
they have nothing but compassion they
see that they see the whole thing
they're seeing their past
from a greater level of Consciousness
right so so now that it resets the
Baseline and the event is over and there
goes the endometriosis there goes the
Suicidal Tendencies there goes the
rashes there goes the gum disease
whatever it is just just the body gets
an upgrade it's no longer believing it's
in the same trauma 24 hours a day seven
days a week 365 days a year because
they're living unconsciously or
subconsciously in that emotional program
right
so so then so then what happens to what
happens to that person
they belong to the Future now they no
longer belong to the past and so it's
almost like they don't even have to do
much now it's almost like they're happy
for no reason and and they're okay with
themselves yes and when you're okay with
yourself you're okay with everybody
that's the way it is if you're living in
stress and you're living in survival and
that system is switched on then
everything will be a threat everything
will be a danger everything will be a
reason to rush to be impatient to be
frustrated to be judgmental because
that's that's the Consciousness that's
the emotion we're living by so now you
you have a problem with a co-worker you
have a problem with your partner or
whatever it is that you use as an
example and you have to give a
presentation now now you really have one
of two choices either be victimized
by those conditions in your life and you
stay in that emotional state and I'll
say to you Jay worry that way while I'm
this way because of this person the
circumstance the person or circumstance
is controlling the way I feel in the way
I think anything that controls the way I
feel and the way I think I'm victim to
right okay or I actually can be a
Creator now okay so when it's the
hardest that matters the most okay so
there's gonna be a story a valid story
that's going to go along with those
emotions that you're gonna have to give
up that you can address at another time
from a different state
if you're altered in that state and you
say something you do something you write
the email you send the text you'll
always regret it you'll always say I
should have never said that I should
have never done that we've got to learn
that we're in an altered state at that
time so it's only one of two choices you
either stay there the whole day and tell
everybody that story
or you say okay let me take a moment
remember that this is the experiment
called life okay let me practice getting
relaxed in my Army slow the animal down
let me practice I'll take a few minutes
now let me breathe let me get my state
back let me change everything okay let
me remember who I am who I want to be
when I open my eyes and let me practice
that again now even if you had to do
that 10 times in one day I would say it
was a day worth living I would say it
was a day worth living and when we do
walking meditations
uh in our our Retreats we're doing
walking meditations so you can practice
doing it with your eyes open yeah like
if you're going to be relaxed in your
heart and awake in your brain and you
can do it with your eyes closed okay
let's take it out for a test drive yeah
let me open my eyes let me pay a little
bit more attention to my inner World let
me practice feeling this feeling let me
practice feeling this way and let my
brain do what it does let me get to
finally change my physiology let me
change my state let me walk as the
healed personally walk as the Abundant
person let me walk as if my prayers are
answering me walk in the state if I keep
practicing that over and over it's going
to become a habit right yes so so we hit
it as many ways as we can we have at
least
seven or eight different breaths that we
do because we see how they all work in
the brain
we have all kinds of meditations we have
Sitting meditations we have standing and
walking meditation laying down
meditations because we want you to be
able to do it because your eyes open
with your eyes go standing walking any
way you can so that you don't default
and return back to that person now if
you do default you didn't fail that's a
program you just went unconscious and
how many times
do we have to forget
until we stop forgetting and start
remembering that's the moment of change
no one no one cares how many times you
fell off the bicycle if you ride the
bicycle now you ride the bike so it's
it's the constant process uh every
single day and I think that sometimes we
look for evidence in our life and it
hasn't happened and I think it's so
important that we still show up yeah
yeah because that's the that's where
you're changing the most and when you
get to that point where you could care
less
if it happens or not because you feel so
happy so grateful for who you are get
ready because your life is going to
begin to change in magical ways most of
us tell the story of our past in a
negative Sense on how it's held us back
um
millions of times over our life as
opposed to the story of the future of
what we want to create or who we want to
become
yeah listen again you tell that story
and the latest research on memory says
that memory is creative that in fact
fifty percent of that story you
embellish people make up that story let
me tell you why they make up that story
because they excuse themselves for the
fact that they haven't been able to
change
since that event they'll have to make it
sound worse than it really was to make
it harder to grow and change so that
they can reaffirm their limited sense of
their inability to change so then that
story becomes more and more of a story
it's less of the truth because you got
to work yourself up into a state there
were lions and tigers and they were
right you know they were helicopters
snowstorms everybody was firing bullets
the worst thing you could possibly
imagine and then you've got to feel that
emotion right and then you look at this
oh yeah it must have been really bad now
that's that's your identity now that's
your identity
the more you hold on to that identity of
the past the harder it is to become who
you want to be in the future well here's
here's to answer the other part of your
question when we started talking
how do you get that person out of their
past yeah well we need a week it's not
going to happen if it doesn't happen
overnight no I want them to come right
up against their fear I want them to
come right up against their doubt I want
them to come up against the point where
they're going to give up and quit and
they're going to sit there and nobody
else is giving up and quitting and
they're going to go all in more and
they're going to start believing what
there's something on the other side of
that emotion they're going to believe
that there's something past the story of
their past because they're stretching
themselves out of the known and it takes
a tremendous amount of awareness
repetition information model building
sharing understanding experiencing to
finally have a person get to the point
where they just let go and when they do
the body's liberated from the past and
there's a release of energy and we now
know that there's a formula to teach
people how to do that in fact we're
getting so good at it that the first two
days day and a half sometimes one day in
certain groups of a week-long event
is about retiring that past finishing it
you know this is when the story ends
this is when they get over it now the
next five days
the person's ready to create a new
future and they're not going to have a
problem teaching their body what it
feels like to be in love with life to
feel like all their needs are met that
they're free they are going to fall in
love with it and they are going to begin
to Signal new genes they're going to be
interchanged to brain circuitry the
brain chemistry their immune system
their gene expression they're telling me
is it's all going to happen they're
they're more of that future self and and
they're they're headed to a future now
here's the deal though you got to be
able to sustain that state when you
return back to your life that's the name
of the game you got to be able right you
got to bring the game into your life now
and no person no circumstance no
condition in your life would cause you
to feel the old way again because the
moment you started feeling victimized
the moment you started feeling angry you
just returned to the old self you
disconnected from the energy of your
future and you're back to the energy of
your past because you made a this far in
a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome
to learn how to manifest anything you
want check the video right there next to
me I think you'll love it continue to
believe and I'll see you there this is
the hard part for most people can you
teach your body emotionally what the
future will feel like before it happens
that means you're not waiting for your
wealth to feel abundant you're not
waiting for your success to feel
empowered you're not waiting for your
new relationship